et notre invité politique ce matin
nicolas dupont aignan bonjour merci
beaucoup avec nous candidats à la
présidentielle pour debout la france on
est ensemble pendant un peu plus de 20
minutes prenez une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
toujours à mes côtés crestel bertrand du
groupe la dépêche on va évidemment
parler de votre programme devant de
campagne nicolas dupont aignan mais
d'abord l'actualité on l'a vu en ukraine
ces massacres à bout de chasser corps de
civils retrouvés massacrés après le
retrait de l'armée russe est ce que vous
dites ce matin vladimir poutine devra
rendre des comptes est ce que ce sont
des crimes de guerre pour vous ce sont
des crimes abominables de guerre
j'attends les résultats d'une enquête
internationale de l'onu je ne prononce
pas comme ça et de toute façon quelles
que soient les auteurs c'est abominable
et ça prouve bien que depuis le début je
demande une solution de paix qu'on
aurait pu avoir pour éviter cette guerre
et je continue de proposer mon plan de
paix je pars répétaient toujours la même
chose on est à quatre jours de
l'élection présidentielle française
j'aimerais qu'on parle de la france on a
mis les indigestions quand même sur sur
l'ukraine vous parliez l'onu va demeurer
line ce qui était hier il s'est exprimé
devant le conseil de sécurité pour
réclamer l'exclusion de la russie fait
écouter monsieur élise qui fait ce qu'il
veut mais moi j'ai envie dans cette
affaire gravissime que on est une
expertise de l'onu qu'on entend des deux
parties et on verra qui a commis ces
atrocités et je souhaite qu'on arrête
cette guerre et pour arrêter cette
guerre il faut négocier un plan de paix
voilà maintenant il ya la france
je souhaite vous parler de la foi pour
une sortie du commandement intégré
suivant sa conscience
c'est possible je souhaite trouver un db
ça n'a rien à voir ce qui se passe je
souhaite retrouver une politique
indépendante de la france car je pense
que la voix de la france n'est plus
audible tellement elle est confuse donc
je souhaite retrouver l'indépendance de
la france et tous vos projets sur le
plan économique
notamment sur le plan militaire ce plan
européen c'est de retrouver une france
libre et on revient en france avec un
sujet qui suscite l'inquiétude c'est la
question des ehpad et de la dépendance
le gouvernement a publié hier son
rapport d'inspection des ehpad du groupe
orpea c'est un rapport accablant
nourriture insuffisante pour les
résidents priorité donnée à la
performance financière vous président de
la république que ferez vous pour éviter
ces dérives mais moi le président de la
république et j'aurais fait ce qu'on
aurait dû faire depuis des années c'est
quand on fait des contrôles on prévient
pas 48 heures à l avance jeudi sous des
malik raison écoutez quand vous
contrôlez personnes ya des abus c'est
tout il n'y a plus d'état jeudi
souderait toutes les ars je remettrai
lord au ministère de la santé je recrée
des directions départementales je
suivrai les établissements jeunes et
contrôlerait c'est ça qu'il faut faire
et puis je mettrai des moyens dans la
dépendance pour créer des établissements
publics qui ne font pas du fric sur le
dos de la misère
parce que ça veut dire plus et pas de
priver ou sinon c'est pas il ya des
ehpad privé qui marche très bien et qui
sont pas dans l'appât du gain j'en ai un
dans ma ville remarquable dont les ehpad
qui dépend des faits des actionnaires
bien sûr c'est les groupes mais c'est la
faute de l'état vous savez il n'ya plus
d'état en france c'est un état qui est
gangréné par les cabinets de conseil un
milliard d'euros je crois qu'il faut
quand même rétablir les choses le
rapport du sénat on est ici à public
sénat faut lire ce rapport du sénat sur
le conflit d'intérêts au sommet il faut
voir que là on range apprend qu'à trois
cent mille euros donnés à cabinet
d'études de copains d'emmanuel macron
pour savoir qu'il faut envoyer les
professions de foi par la poste 300
millions mais c'est un état dans grainé
au sommet qui est toujours au service
d'intérêts financiers donc que l'état
par exemple a pu protéger on va faire
une enquête là aussi qu'est ce qui se
passe pourquoi tant
non je ne suis pas emmanuel macron sur
ce sujet j'accuse emmanuel macron sur
les cabinets de conseil et je dis aux
français qu avec moi je ferai un grand
ménage au sommet de l'état je veux
rétablir une fonction publique d'état où
il n'ya pas d'intervenant du privé où il
n'y a pas de conflit d'intérêt permanent
et jeudi et j'en profite de le dire
parce que dans notre pays on peut pas
dire grand chose je dis que par exemple
parquet financier le parquet financier a
disparu de notre pays
deux cabinets de conseils de mckinsey de
conflit d'intérêts au sommet et on
serait dans une démocratie normale le
président de la république pourrait pas
se représenter et d'ailleurs il va même
pu voir les journalistes on a vu hier
qu'il n'a pas été voir france 2 il a
tellement peur des questions je serai
cabinet de conseil hier bruno retailleau
votre place disait qu'ils étaient proche
de françois fillon qui est proche de
françois fillon il dit à deux poids deux
mesures en 2010 elle vient
je le dis je l' ai déjà dit il y a un
président de la république qui devrait
faire l'objet d'une enquête du parquet
financier sur son patrimoine personnel
sur sur sur ses déclarations de
patrimoine sur la fère mckinsey et à
rien silence radio mais les français ont
compris qu'ils se passait quelque chose
de très grave au sommet de l'état et je
dis aux français et ce qu'ils veulent
continuer cinq ans de plus avec l'argent
sur son compte mail j'en en scène une
enquête parce que quand on gagne autant
pendant des années
la vie publique fait pas son travail
écoutez c'est bizarre moi j'aimerai
savoir j'aimerais savoir comment on peut
gagner autant d'argent et avoir ainsi
fait partie moines
donc pour vous la haute autorité n'a pas
fait son travail je demande à l'autorité
de faire son travail et je dis très
clairement au delà de ça que c'est ce
deux poids deux mesures dont vous
parliez qui interpelle les français moi
je m'en parle dans la rue ils me disent
mais c'est quoi cette république
bananière c'est quoi on est où et je les
appelle à sanctionner emmanuel macron
dans les urnes tel premier tour et
j'appelle les français quelle que soit
leur couleur politique qui ne veulent
plus de ces conflits d'intérêts de ce
gaspillage c'est l'argent de la peine
des français avec 1 milliard vous savez
ce qu'on faisait
là des conjugale isation de l'allocation
adulte handicapé qu'on a tous voté de
gauche et de droite à l'assemblée mais
que l'on marche a refusé pourquoi ils
ont refusé ils nous ont dit ça coûte 800
millions on peut pas mais au même moment
on donne un milliard au cabinet de
conseil mais enfin mais où on vit donc
moi je dis aux français maintenant
réveillez vous est ce que voulait
reprendre cinq ans comme ça ou non c'est
ça l'enjeu l'enjeu de l'élection c'est
d'agir avant qu'il ne soit trop tard et
a pas que sur les cabinets conseil
assure la retraite à 65 ans il ya sur
les universités payante que fra emmanuel
macron ya surtout ça et je suis très
surpris d'ailleurs d'être le seul
candidat presque qui annonce les périls
qui essayent de dialoguer de manière
interposés avec ce pouvoir était les
candidats sont très très atone je trouve
on va parler d'une affaire d'actualité
c'est la sphère jérémy quand même ce
jeune homme qui est mort percuté par un
tram ans alors qu'ils prenaient la fuite
suite à une violente agression par un
groupe de jeunes en déplacement hier
dans le finistère emmanuel macron a
réagi l'assurer que ça à sa famille
qu'il était à leurs côtés que les mines
et suivait le dossier depuis le début et
il a mis en garde contre les
récupérations peu laitiers qu'en pensez
vous mais il ment aux français pourquoi
ils m'ont parce que s'il n'y avait pas
eu la bataille du papa de jérémy dit
rien ce serait passer l'affairé fin
quand il dit que les ministres de cette
peur du tout il m'en est en fait c'est
pire que ça c'est qu'en fait il veut
cacher la dérive d'insécurité qui a dans
le pays et tout est fait pour étouffer
les affaires qu'est ce qui vous permet
de dire qu'il ment mérite pas ce que le
pape a été obligé d'alerté quand vous
pensez ce qu'on trouve normal que dans
une république
votre fils est écrasé par un tramway
parce qu'il est agressée on a les vidéos
abominable et rien ne se passe entre le
17 février et fin mars
rien mais qu'est ce qui vous permet de
gérer le gouvernement ne suivaient pas
ce dossier avant qu'il soit bien et mais
enfin tout cas s'il suivait ce dossier
le papa aurait eu des nouvelles je veux
dire que enfin c'est abominable
vous savez vous savez qu'à faire comme
ça jusqu'à mes cils s'il a tempêté temps
vous imaginez dans cette affaire mais
moi ce que je veux c'est qu'on soit dans
un pays mis à là malheureusement n'y a
pas que me que jérémy il ya des affaires
partout qui sont enfouis enterrer une
justice qui n'intervient pas qu'il
n'agit pas c'est gravissime et tout est
fait notamment par une certaine presse
du pouvoir pour dissimuler ce genre de
drames qu'elle n'a pas montré que ils
veulent cacher la sécurité qui a dans le
pays avant les élections
c'est tout ils ont peur que les français
découvrent ce qui se passe dans leur
propre pays et donc l'insécurité a
explosé en france pendant emmanuel
dessous le mobicat kenna d'emmanuel gros
vous avez dit chiche ça a été peu caché
quand même ça paye cash et
des raisons électoralistes tout est fait
pour cacher aux préférable et l'ukraine
c'est tellement plus simple un comme ça
des français voient pas ce qui se passe
dans leur propre pays on va parler de la
corse puisque sept ans dans leur propre
pays pour le coup si vous êtes élu y
aura un dossier corse à gérer puisque
dès le gouvernement a promis des
discussions sur la question de
l'autonomie ya encore des violences il
ya encore des violences dimanche du coup
le gouvernement a stoppé les discussions
a ajourné la réunion est ce que vous si
vous êtes élu président de la république
vont poursuivre et ses discussions avec
les élus corses d'abord il a eu raison
ou la journée les discussions l'envoyé
je suis pas toujours dans l'opposition
et il a eu raison d'ajourner discussion
chez un des seul candidat à avoir été en
corse tout de suite dès les 1 6 premiers
incidents j'ai dit au corps ce que je
pensais je leur ai dit
vous avez déjà une autonomie
considérable mais qu'est ce que vous
faites qu'est ce que font vos élus il
n'exerce pas le problème des déchets
toujours pas réglé vous avez un champ
incroyable de pouvoir que la république
nous a transférés c'est le quatrième
statut et vous faites quoi vous en
seriez un cinquième donc faut arrêter
les manipulations là aussi d'une
minorité indépendantiste qui ne se
satisfait jamais de ce qu'elle a et qui
veut tout plus mais exercer déjà ce que
vous avez en revanche la nullité de
l'assemblée de corse 1 sur le fait qu'il
faut poursuivre ces discussions mais
ruby servait de corse devrait exercer
les compétences qu'elle a avant d'en
chercher d'autres un premier point
deuxième point il ya des domaines
notamment la spéculation qui chasse les
corses de leurs terres les jaunes qui
est un vrai problème qui se pose pas
qu'en corse qui se posent dans toutes
les cellules terres côtières si je puis
dire c'est à dire dans toutes les zones
à fortes spéculations dans le midi de la
france dans l'ouest de la france et là
il faut qu'on trouve une solution
par une vraie action publique de
prévention par exemple de préemption la
suisse dans certains cantons très riche
à trouver des solutions parce que là
vous savez un problème pour notre
jeunesse pas qu'en corse et qui pourrit
l'avenir de notre jeunesse liées aux
inégalités entre les mairies par exemple
aurait au moins je souhaite m'en je
souhaite qu'on trouve une solution
vraiment parce que vous savez c'est un
problème qu'avant toute la france pas
con corse et je les dis aux corses donc
moi je ne suis pas fermé à des
discussions sur des points précis mais
calmons le jeu et évitons de partir dans
un délire autonomistes exerçant les
compétences et puis apaisant en trouvant
des solutions sur des problèmes que les
corses à juste titre soulève sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est la principale
préoccupation des français
alors la première mesure j'ai présenté
la liste des produits de première
nécessité c'est une proposition de loi
que j'ai faite en avril 2019 d'envoyer
je ne suis pas réveillée avec les
élections
une vingtaine de produits de première
nécessité qu'on passe à 0 % de tva
l'idée étant de faire baisser le taux à
10 ans par exemple et les couches il ya
eu d'ailleurs j'ai vu une proposition de
loi au sénat il ya longtemps qu a pas
été acceptée par le gouvernement pour
mettre les couches à 5,5 vous savez que
ça 20% le paquet de couches la tva donc
je souhaite qu'on la descende à 0% le
dentifrice et produits d'hygiène il ya
un sondage abominable 37% des français
se privent combien de produits 31
nécessité alors là une vanne mais on
peut l'étendre jeudi une vingtaine parce
que moi je rase pas gratis mais je veux
par exemple que sur ces vins produits on
a fait le caddie j'ai montré qu on
baissait de 10 % quand même la facture
sur un caddie 200 euros je redonne dix
euros de pouvoir d'achat ça c'est
immédiat vous proposez aussi plafonner
le prix de l'essence a conduit un euro
70 je propose aussi de ré indexer les
pensions de retraite sur l'inflation je
propose enfin
8% un 13e mois pour tous les salariés
jusqu'à 3 smic dégressif après payer
attention pas par les entreprises qui
n'ont pas les moyens mais par la baisse
des charges salariales vous savez la
différence entre le brut et le net vous
financier comment par la lutte contre
les gaspillages de l'état et par la
contribution à l'union européenne que je
descends c'est à dire je ne veux plus
qu'on donne il faut que les français le
sachent pas ce que j'en parle depuis peu
et français me dit c'est pas possible on
donne temps 10 milliards net
c'est-à-dire qu'on donne 10 milliards de
plus qu'on reçoit quand on donne 25
milliards on en reçoit que 15 l'union
européenne
si on a multiplié par dix ans mais
j'insiste on a multiplié par dix
dépenses en vingt ans par 10 c'est le
budget de l'enseignement supérieur qu'on
donne à bruxelles je veux mettre fin à
ça on donnera un milliard ça suffit
largement et je reprends 9 milliards qui
me permettent de récompenser le travail
des français ou qui ont travaillé les
retraités j'avais cru comprendre que le
financier aussi par la suppression de
millions de cas oui bien sûr aussi un
taux de 6,20 milliards mais la cnam dix
depuis 2000 18 y en a plus oui mais la
caam à tort et je vais vous dire
pourquoi elle a tort parce que le
rapport du sénat que vous connaissez le
rapport de l'assemblée le rapport de la
cour des comptes le rapport de
l'inspection générale des finances ça
fait beaucoup bu et tous tous sont entre
2 millions et 7 millions de fausses
cartes vitales qui 2 millions 7 millions
la cnam événements mais c'est normal
puisque la cnam a échoué et a laissé
pourrir un système et donc elle va pas
dire
j'ai tort et d'ailleurs vous si vous
regardez les témoignages des sénateurs
c'est madame boulaire de mémoire
nathalie goulet devant l'assemblée où
devant le sénat je sais plus la
directrice à l'époque de la sécurité
sociale a fait un faux témoignage c'est
à dire qu'elle a dit oui à deux millions
de fausses cartes et après elle a envoyé
un communiqué disant non il y en a pas
autant donc ça veut dire qu'en fait la
cnam cache un drame et à gaspillage
gigandet dont je vais retirer à la cnam
la gestion des cartes vitale que vous
confierez acquis et ben organisme
indépendant m et de manière à avoir une
garantie et je tirerai au sort des
citoyens qui seront le les garants et
qui surveilleront ce système parce que
je peux vous dire que les retraités vous
retirez les la gestion de cardy chaldu
étudiants sur de la surveillance et carl
vous faites une assemblée de citoyens
sauve les citoyens qui va surveiller les
gaspillages de leur argent parce que
vous savez il y aura un cd sénateurs des
députés aussi la cour des comptes les
grandes institutions et puis des
citoyens tirés au sort qui parce que
c'est leur argent vous savez moi je vois
des retraités j'ai vu un retraité là en
corse quand j étais qu est venu me voir
et m'a dit monsieur j'ai travaillé
quarante deux ans j'ai 820 euros de
retraite j'en avais 880 avant emmanuel
macron 890
voilà je peux plus vivre je vais au
resto du coeur j'ai pas si vous avez vu
le rapport du resto du coeur il hier un
article dans le figaro 40 % de jeunes le
toujours plus de monde mais notre pays
ne veut pas continuer comme ça je suis
un gaulliste social moi j'accepte
passage n'accepterai pas ça et ça c'est
lié parce qu'il ya des gaspillages donc
je veux rendre l'argent à ceux qui en
ont besoin un mot sur la question
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux
le numerus clausus a été supprimée ce
qu'on peut aller plus loin est ce qu'il
faut trouver d'autres idées alors
d'abord une première chose parce que je
réfléchis y a pas de solution miracle et
celui qui va vous dire il ya plus d
airmédic surtout hambourg terme mais
j'ai une solution à court terme que j'ai
trouvée elle vaut ce qu'elle vaut c'est
pendant la campagne voyez comme quoi
c'est utile campagne
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de médecins et
tous me disent la même chose qu'ils ont
à peu près entre 10 et 20% de tâches
administratives
et donc je me suis dit comment on peut
pas inventer des médecins
si on recrutait des comme des greffiers
dans la justice des assistants
administratifs
pour retirer payé par client ne l'a pas
par la sécurité sociale qui retiraient
toutes les tâches administratives des
médecins que les médecins n'est plus un
formulaire à remplir rien et que l'on
bascule ainsi 10 à 20% de leur temps
vous imaginez l'équivalent de médecins
ce que ça représente je connais des
médecins notamment des médecins du
travail qui sur leurs quatre jours de
travail ont une journée pour faire leurs
dossiers je sais pas si vous réalisez
donc on va essayer de faire un big bang
administratif dans la médecine créer des
assistants par département par bassin de
vie qui s'occuperont plusieurs médecins
avec l'informatique on devrait y arriver
avec le numérique et dégager les
médecins et puis je veux recréer un
hôpital rouvrir un hôpital par
département dans les zones par exemple
l'hôpital de saint-claude qui a été
réduit comme peau de chagrin dans le
jura le maire m'expliquer on va lui
rendre le laboratoire la cardiologie on
va rouvrir ce qui va permettre d'avoir
d'enquêté identifié ça c'est à dire que
certains services n'étaient pas la route
mais c'est pas vrai je vais me dire ça
c'était le prétexte donné par les ars
pour tuer les petits hôpitaux alors on
pourra pas tout rouvrir attention ils
ont supprimé 100 mille lits en 20 ans
emmanuel macron en a supprimé
17300 je veux en rouvrir 20000 c'est à
dire à peu près ce qu'emmanuel macro à
supprimer voilà et puis une bourse pour
les jeunes internes on perd à leurs
études et en échange ils s'engagent à
faire des vacations dans des zones
désertifiées sur l'environnement oui le
jak2 rendu un nouveau rapport cette
semaine toujours plus accablant dans
votre programme vous me semblez vous
attaquez qu'à deux domaines l'énergie et
l'isolation des bâtiments or le giec dit
il va falloir travailler aussi sur la
pollution liée à l'industrie
sur l'agriculture
pourquoi elles seront concentrées sur
ces deux domaines là pour une raison
très simple le giec a raison mais la
france aurait tort
de d'aller encore plus loin alors même
qu'elle est exemplaire et que son point
faible ce sont les bâtiments donc je
concentre l'effort français là où on
n'est pas bon c'est à dire les passoires
thermiques en revanche j'estime que ce
sont la chine l'allemagne la pologne
l'inde les états unis qui font sauter la
planète et je dis aux français la
meilleur moyen de sauver la planète
c'est de ne plus acheter chinois et ni
allemand parce que mais également
l'allemagne route des centrales à
charbon l'allemagne a refusé nucléaire
l'allemagne nous impose un modèle
paulhan et l'accueil au boycott au
boycott mais je dis aux français si vous
voulez protéger la planète arrêté
d'acheter des produits chinois également
parce que c'est bien d'être le dette le
pays qui se suicident industriellement
vous savez on a baissé notre gaz à effet
de serre de 21% à 21 % mais par les
produits importés on l'a augmentée 70%
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'en fait on a transféré notre
pollution donc moi je voudrais que les
rapports du giec soient respectées par
tous les pays la france est le pays qui
polluent le moins revanche on a une
faiblesse en isolation thermique le
gouvernement a commencé avec ma prime
rénova faire des efforts mais qui sont
insuffisants et je bascule l'aide aux
éoliennes qui ne servent à rien j'arrête
les éoliennes je les achète toute
construction de nouvelles constructions
et je les bascules les 3 milliards vers
l'isolation thermique pour que les
ménages notamment les plus modestes
réduisent leurs factures et qu'on est en
finisse avec les cinq millions de
passoires thermiques ça c'est concret
nicolas dupont aignan on est à quelques
jours du premier tour l'élection
présidentielle la plupart des sondages
me voir tous les sondages disent que
marine le pen est presque assurée
d'arriver au second tour est ce que vous
allez la soutenir mais on verra qui sera
au second tour les sondages se sont
trompés à 10 points n'y a pas longtemps
il ya un an
donc arrêtons avec les sondages voté moi
je dis aux français voter en fonction de
vos convictions je serai le candidat de
la liberté notamment n'a pas parlé de ça
j'annulerai le pass sanitaire le pass
vaccinale la loi d'état d'urgence je
réintégrerai tous les soignants exclu
jeu
je mets en garde les français je suis le
seul candidat qui est clair et j'appelle
les millions de français qui sont non
vaccinés j'appelle les millions de
français qui n'ont put pas sanitaires à
prendre garde si emmanuel macron au dot
été élu eh bien il serait à nouveau en
prison je suis le seul qui va les
libérer et plus j'aurai de voir plus on
pèsera pour arrêter l'escroquerie
du pass sanitaire qui est toujours
maintenue à l'hôpital donc moi je suis
candidat pour rendre la liberté aux
français je suis le seul qui a été clair
et je dis aux français aidez moi plus
long sera nombreux plus on pèsera plus
peut-être on aura une bonne surprise au
second tour donc
le plus de voix possible si possible au
second tour des millions de français qui
disent dupont aignan était le sol qui
nous a protégés qui a bataillé pendant
la crise sanitaire avec florian
philippot tous les autres se sont mis
sous la table j'ai été à l'assemblée
vous en souvenez mais petite vidéo qui
ont fait des millions de vues et je dis
à tous est tous ces français qui ont été
persécutés je le redis e et des mois et
des mois parce qu'avec moi vous aurez
une politique sanitaire 'juste qui
luttent contre le coc ville mais qui
n'en prison' pas les français
oui est ce que on voit monter un
sentiment de tout sauf emmanuel macron
est-ce que vous participerait à ce
mouvement mais j ai je suis le plus en
pointe
parce que je dis aux français moi je
vais vous dire je veux qu'on ait un
autre second tour je veux qu'on ait un
second tour sans macron voilà ça ça
serait la bonne nouvelle parce que il y
aurait d'abord plusieurs candidats et je
pense sincèrement que si les français
aujourd'hui n'ont pas envie d'aller
voter c'est pas ce qu'on leur dit toute
la journée qu'ils vont retrouver second
tour de des milices montpensier qui peut
ne pas être je l'espère je fais tout
pour mais c'est pas moi qui vais décider
j'aimerais dire ce qui m'inquiète on
restera entre nous et on campagne ou
être totalement transparent c'est que
j'ai peur que les français n'avaient pas
voté et la campagne a commencé très
tardivement je les voyais rejeté au
tréport je vois des gens à la fois très
motivé mais j'en vois aussi beaucoup et
qui auraient raté vous un politique est
vrai que les français alors là c'est pas
les hommes politiques excusez moi un jeu
vous dire franchement nous bataille
depuis des mois on va plus à l'excès
alors là ne le prenez pas mal n'est ce
pas vous personnellement parce que
public sénat est une chaîne qui s'il ya
une chaîne qui parle des problèmes c'est
vous mais écoutez on a eu on a eu très
peu d'émissions n'y a pas eu de débat on
n'a parlé que du coc vide on n'a parlé
que de l'ukraine les français sont
complètement ensevelies il ça passe pas
que par la télé ça passe par les
déplacements non
une campagne c'est ça mais il ya eu très
peu de campagnes médiatiques
il ya eu des sujets qu'on télescoper ya
pas toujours un grand complot médiatique
rassurez vous mais il ya eu un
enchaînement de phénomènes et puis à hua
hin emmanuel macron cas pas voulu de
campagne jean est et reste plus à la
police at et respect parce qu'on
l'aurait d'abord parce qu'on leur
présente toujours les mêmes
personnalités et que excusez moi mais
pendant les kits et moi j'ai eu très peu
de temps de parole ça fait l'égalité
depuis deux semaines donc la campagne
elle commence là depuis huit jours à
damas il ya énormément d'indécis et les
gens vont se dessiner leurs bons et je
leur dis mais réveillez-vous rapidement
puisque vous parlez de l'assemblée tout
à l'heure vous serez à nouveau candidat
aux législatives ah ben je serai
président la république je vais pas être
candidat à l'assemblée voilà donc je me
présente à la présidence de la
république je vais pas faire comme eric
zemmour hier je crois que dit la
législation j'étais surpris parce que ça
veut dire que tu crois pas en lui c'est
pas possible quand non non moi je
produis les législatives ce que vous
êtes aussi président de parti il y aura
des alliances entre votre parti est
celui d'eric via une alliance avec
florian philippot pour qu'ils aient déjà
lancé des souverainistes de ceux qui
veulent l'indépendance les relations
non aux législatives il ya une alliance
avec florian philippot le reste je ne
sais pas où nous serons le 10 avril moi
je ne fais entre avec la
présentera des candidats partout mais
j'aurais d'ailleurs plus tard on a
compris je ne sais pas du tout nous
serons le 10 avril moi je me rends mais
aux français c'est eux qui ont tous
entre les mains j'aimerais tellement les
convaincre vous savez qu'ils aillent
voter si nicolas dupont aignan merci
beaucoup a invité la une de la dépêche
les programmes programme lésés et
comparée à celle de la présenter dans
l'ensemble très bien puisqu'on a eu des
comparatifs avant les gars des cités
le groupe ebra tous les autres vraiment
merci la presse de province merci
nicolas dupont aignan d'avoir été notre
invité merci que les stèles
[Musique]